you know the last time I heard acapella
this good was on where in the world is
Carmen Sandiego Shu Babu picked away who
bow pitch perfect stars Anna Kendrick
and it's a film about rival acapella
groups all competing for the big award
of who is the best acapella group Anna
Kendrick plays a kind of reserved young
girl she's starting college and she
joins this club kind of apprehensively
and she starts to really enjoy it they
put on these shows there's these other
rival acapella groups and they fight
with each other kind of the same time
she meets this guy who oddly resembles
Dane Cook a disease that seems to be
spreading through many people these days
unfortunately if you like Dane Cook I
apologize not only for just offending
you probably but for the fact that you
have no comedic sensibilities whatsoever
anyway and so we get to see these two
rival acapella groups kind of battling
it out for the gold basically it's kind
of like bring it on except with a
cappella because it has that same super
peppy feel you know everyone's just like
yeah singing whoo singing yeah and also
times has that corniness to it as well
where it's like wow this is really
sugary sweet to extreme levels and
you're just sort of cringing at times
that being said though this is not an
awful movie as I expected going in
because I saw this movie actually about
a month and a half ago and I wasn't able
to review it until now so I had really
no expectations going in no one had seen
it they actually said it was probably
one of the first screenings held for the
film which was pretty cool the movie is
alright it's not that bad Anna Kendrick
is really likable in this movie I liked
her character I really liked how into
music she was she graded her own music
she was trying to get her music noticed
and she joined this acapella group just
to kind of please her father who wanted
her to be in this club I liked that
aspect of the film I like the
competition aspect of it too that was
always fun to watch the performances
were a lot of fun too and the music was
great you know it sounded really cool a
lot of the acapella songs were catchy
they did songs they were actually good
for the most part not just current pop
culture songs that are not good at all
like I actually had some good classic
music in there so the rivalries in the
movie were super super cliched like to
insane levels where you got like the
over-the-top bad guy who's like you know
this comedian in real life who he was
pretty funny in the movie but one of my
problems with this movie was that there
were certain characters who had story
arcs that never came to fruition in any
way
his character didn't really lead to
anything and it felt really like a loose
end there were other characters in the
film that just didn't really feel like
complete characters and they were just
there to be themselves to play the exact
same character they play in every movie
like rebel Wilson every film I have seen
her in she generally tends to play a
sexually assertive woman
self-deprecating of her weight and
slightly mentally retarded she always
plays the exact same character and I
just don't find her funny and she annoy
me in this movie I got to say some of
the rivalries were really cheesy and
everything but some of them were
actually pretty entertaining the movie
has some extreme gross-out humor at
times that really shocked me that I
won't spoil for you but it was actually
pretty funny for the most part I enjoyed
pitch-perfect is it a great movie no not
at all is it a bad movie no it's not
it's actually a mod Lee fun film it's
enjoyable it's not perfect it has its
problems but it does have its fun times
as well I'm gonna give pitch-perfect a
b-minus I think that fans have saved the
glee TV show or people who are really
looking forward to this movie who don't
care about anything I just said you will
love it I'm sure but for the most part I
would say just maybe check this one out
when it comes out on DVD thanks a lot
for watching guys and as always if you
like this and you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
Oh